Hello and welcome to today's episode of Rawkode
live. I am your host Rawkode
and
today we are gonna be taking a look
at a CNCF
project,
CoreDNS.
Before we move on to that, I just
wanna take a moment to say thank you
to my employer. They provide me the time
to invest and help produce these episodes that
we can take a look at the modern
cloud native landscape and purchase learning materials for
us all to learn together. So thank you
Equinix metal. There is a code, Rawkode Live.
You can use that when signing up or
even if you're already a customer, you can
still use this coupon. It will get you
50 US dollars in credits, which you can
use in a couple of hours with some
beefy machines or spread out over longer term
with some smaller machines. Either way, the choice
is yours.
If you want to have a conversation afterwards,
there is a Discord server. You can come
and join and ask questions or just ask
for news show suggestions. I am open to
anything and if you're not watching live, this
is the best way to interact.
Now, we're gonna take a look at CoreDNS
and for that I have the founder,
Mick Haven. How are you Mick? Hello. I'm
fine. Thanks. Thanks for asking me.
No. This is awesome. I'm really looking forward
to learning more about CoreDNS and who better
to do it than you. So this is
gonna be fantastic.
Do you wanna just take a moment to
introduce yourself and tell us a little bit
about you and the and the project?
Yeah. We've been
in London for a couple of years. Moved
back recently to The Netherlands where I live
now.
And I have been doing DNS for a
long time.
Involved in DNSSEC in in February.
At some point, I
got involved in SkyDNS,
which was the thing that got used in
Kubernetes.
Via via some ideas, this led to me
actually writing a new DNS server,
which is CoreDNS, which we're gonna talk about
tonight.
Okay. Great. So
let me start with a couple of questions
that I kind of prepared in advance then.
So when I think of DNS, you know,
I've been doing operational work for nearly twenty
years now, and Bind was just always that
one thing that I had installed on my
server.
Why did we need to change the status
quo there? Why did we have to bring
in something new?
Yeah. Note that there is Bind, there is
NSD, there is PowerDNS,
there's a couple of DNS servers and and
precursors.
Mostly, you don't need a new DNS server
off the bat.
The interesting thing here is that I wanted
a new DNS server, and I was capable
enough to actually write one.
And it's one of the few that's not
written in a c language.
So off the bat, there are a couple
of things that are better. It just crashes.
There are no buffer overflow and that kind
of stuff. So that that's a big difference
from the current crop of of DNS servers.
Being written in Go, you have GCs, so
there might be more overhead, so speed might
be an issue.
But, yeah, in general, I would recommend against
writing a DNS server,
But to just break the molds and have
something new in the ecosystem, I think CoreDNS
is a very good good idea.
Also, if you look at DNS, the protocol
is is fairly complex nowadays,
and I don't know from the top of
my head any new DNS servers that have
grown, like, CoreDNS did in the past year.
Like, it's it's bind is from
the eighties.
LSD is almost twenty year old now. PowerDNS
has also been around for a long time.
I don't know exactly how long, but there
hasn't been any new DNS software
in the last decade, I think, except for
CoreDNS.
So just something kinda popped in my head
there as you were talking. Like, I guess,
you know, DNS is as old as the
Internet. Right? At least as as what we
think of. Is it is that protocol still
evolving? Is it still changing, or is it
relatively static?
So the core of the protocol has been
static since nineteen eighty four ish,
but a lot of stuff has happened. I
mean, it's called plain text. It's easy to
spoof. So there was this effort in a
sec that actually made it more secure.
That made a protocol way more complex, and
not everybody is actually using it. So it's
it's questionable if that was a good idea.
And and because it's all like, it runs
on UDP
and having to do your own networking with
UDP is is pretty hard.
So you see new things popping up, which
actually are in the presentation. The protocol called
Do is DNS over HTTP,
which is interesting. And, QUIC is a new
protocol being
finalized, I think, by the ITF. So DOC
is another thing that's coming along, which means
we're gonna do DNS over QUIC. So there's
a lot of stuff happening in that that
area as well. And
corner cases are still being found, and they
need an RC to to detail them and
how that
actually properly works. So even though it's an
old protocol,
a lot of new things are happening in
in that space. The core protocol has been
static as I said for for decades now.
That's pretty cool. Okay.
So, again, I mean, DNS sec, you you've
mentioned that twice now, and it's one of
those things that I know I'm supposed to
enable on my domains, and then I just
never actually do. So
I'm sure I should. I probably will try
it one day, but I'm I'll skip it
for now. It it's it's complex. Although I
wrote thing for that in CoreDNS because we
got annoyed with it as well. And and
why are you just getting better and even
as the EmpowerDNS have a good tuning for
that as well. But, no, you do it
on your server and nobody validates those signatures
you're adding, it don't add any value.
Ah, okay. It sounds like you're kinda scratching
a lot of your own edges or pain
points with CoreDNS. It's like you're getting frustrated
with things and you're going, right. I can
do this better. Is is that a fair
guess or assumption?
Yeah. Well, that's how it started because I
wanna make a few metrics from bind, and
bind doesn't do this out of the box.
So you have intermediate binary which compiles some
stuff from
XML,
but bind output it at a time. So
that led to me thinking
I have this Go DNS library, which is
pretty okay.
How hard can it be to actually write
a DNS server?
And
at the time, I was looking at a
new web server for the whole lesson group
stuff. And, Gedi,
a Go server written by Matt Holt, did
all that stuff, and that looked pretty amazing.
And that got me thinking, like, maybe I
can use the same model that Kelly is
using and just run the NSR.
And that's actually I forked Kelly and basically
replaced HTTP with DNS and the source code
after two weeks of failure.
Compile it, and it was resembling a DNS
server. So that was pretty much my own
itch to and it did, of course, for
metrics.
So that was my own itch that I
scratched and that wasn't into into CoreDNS.
Amazing. And
that's great that you had the CADI project
there or something you could just kinda use
as, I guess, the server boilerplate and then
work in all the DNS logic and stuff
like that. Yep. Yep. Yeah. The whole web
API here is is is copied from. Okay?
Very cool.
So I believe we're gonna start today's session
with a little bit of a introduction and
some slides.
So I'll get your
Yep. There we go. Your slides are now
live.
Thank you.
Yeah. So as we just discussed, like, CoreDNS,
very
much emphasis on on a flexible server.
The the the the plug in idea that
we briefly touched upon
makes it easy to add stuff in CoreDNS,
so you don't need to be a full
expert to add stuff
working in your server.
And also discuss DNS looks like a very
simple protocol, but there's many corner cases which
makes it really, really tricky to to deal
with. And also people expect speed, so it
also needs to be blazingly fast. Otherwise, you
get latencies in in all your application.
So let's talk about the plug ins.
Without plug ins, CoreDNS basically doesn't do anything,
and
a a plugin is similar to
a web server spec middleware.
The original word in CoreDNS was even middleware,
which at the time used middleware and plugins.
We settled on plugins at some point.
We have quite a bit,
I think 30 ish,
and they are all configured compile time.
And we have a file called plug in
dot config, which tells you what plug ins
are available in in CoreDNS.
Here you see a couple of them.
Metadata,
that's a plug in that adds some a
little bit of metadata like
MAC address. You can add that if you
want.
Cancel is to cancel a context
on the
on the query. TLS is to set up
TLS, which is useful for DNS of HTTP,
for instance, or or gRPC.
Reload will reload the CoreDNS process
if it sees changes in its config file.
So there's a whole range of what plugins
can do,
but it's all implemented as as a plugin.
NSID stands for name server ID. It's a
little tag you could add to a DNS
request,
that tells you when you hit an Anycast
server, which server actually responded to your request.
So that could be useful for debugging. So
there's a whole range of stuff that we
have in in in CoreDNS.
So one of the things that people struggle
with is
in which order
are the plugins processed when the CoreDNS sees
a query.
And the order is
done compile time, and the order is what
the order is in plugin dot config.
So it doesn't matter how your config looks.
The order is already predetermined
by
compiling this file into CoreDNS, so to speak.
So
looking at config special specifies with weapons you
have and then which order they will be
executed.
And the core file, which is the config
file for CoreDNS,
specifies the plug in usage for your specific
server.
It would be nice if this was all
dynamic.
Go doesn't do this yet. Maybe in some
future rewrite, we will revisit this whole idea
and it becomes more natural.
For now, this is how we do things.
So to look specifically,
if I have a config file, a core
file
with,
the following plugins,
cache,
where am I, log,
Then if I get a query from from
the outside to CoreDNS,
I need to look into the plug in
of config and see where these plug ins
are actually configured.
So cache is on line 44,
where am I is on line 64, and
log is on line 37.
Meaning log will be seen first,
then cash will see the query, and then
who am I? We'll see the query, and
then you can reply.
So the ordering
here in the core file doesn't
matter on how this query is being processed.
So can I ask a question about that
if you're happy to take them at all?
Yeah. I just I I guess
That's a good thing, though. Right? I'm assuming
that the the plug in developers and yourself
and the other contributors, you you understand the
order and semantics that sense for each of
these plugins rather than leaving it into the
hands of the person right in their own
core file where they could have
cash at the very end and then never
actually being used at all. So I guess
this this is a good feature and I
guess something that people just need to be
aware of.
Yes or no. So we get we'll get
bug reports by people saying, like, my plug
in is not executed,
and that's, like, where it is, where do
do you put the plug in in your
plug in config, which is, like, I put
it last, which is, yeah, then it won't
get seen probably.
But sometimes you have two plug ins that
need to be on precision five, for instance.
And then you need to make a decision
which one goes first,
which if you could just revert the order
in the
core file, you wouldn't have that problem.
Okay.
So yeah. It's yeah. It is what it
is.
Could could be better. I quite like this
because it's really too too realistic, and you
can just see what what's happening.
On those plug ins, we have a whole
range of them. We are discussing,
do we need to make this an official
type of plugin? But there are so many,
and it's so liberal what you can do
in the plugin. It's it's pretty hard to
do this properly.
But we have plugins that generate some
response.
Who am I forward, which goes to another
server to fetch response and return it.
Kubernetes plugin,
which gets its data from the Kubernetes API.
Other things are queries that are inspected.
A lock is such a thing. It doesn't
really inspect it, but it it looks at
the query and then partnership unlocks what what
it sees.
Cache,
obviously, will catch the query, so it will
see the query, put it in its cache
if the response isn't there yet.
You can inspect the query and change it,
rewrite template, both sides, all do this. MSID
is one of those as well.
You have plug ins that affect the whole
process.
Health
used in in Kubernetes to report
health endpoint.
Ready readiness, another thing used in Kubernetes.
Reload, we saw this.
All you can do if you reload a
config file, sorry, you can actually do the
a a binary on this
and metrics that actually exports
Prometheus metrics.
It's one of the reasons that I actually
wanted coordinates for purpose.
And for Core file hamper helpers, you can
import
another file or a snippet to make your
Core file readable.
Each of these has a readme.
They're all published on CoreDNS.io.
I made a W package where our package
is all as manual pages as well. So
that that's a good set of documentation.
It mostly tells you how to use
a plugin.
Becomes interesting if there's interaction between different plugins
and and how you debug stuff, which is
something we will see, later in this presentation
on on plugins that might help you there.
Okay. Let's delve into
not to work. Into a a config and
see how this works.
So we have two config files.
This one is plain DNS, and what does
it say?
I am authoritative for the root zone, which
is basically the entirety of of DNS.
And I will run on this port number,
and this server will have a whoever plug
in and a log plug in.
Meaning, it will respond to it, and it
will log this.
The new protocol, though, DNS over HTTP,
similar thing except you just prefix
the domain
with HTTPS
colon slash slash. I'm not sure what Quick
will do, but it
probably also gonna be HTTPS. I'm not sure
how we're gonna make that different in in
a core file.
It needs to run on a different port
in this case, so we do this one.
Also, this plugin,
log plugin, and I need TLS
configured for though it doesn't work if you
don't have TLS.
This this is interesting,
especially if you look at, for instance, and
let's encrypt.
It would be cool if we could automate
this in a similar way, but being a
DNS server has some
interesting
things that we need to look at.
Let's let's see how this work. Let's shift
to
my terminal.
So
I have a couple of things here.
I found a parking utility called Homer, which
actually speaks DNS over HTTP
because because my go to utility deck doesn't
do it yet.
So I have a
core file here, which is basically the thing
I just shown you.
It's one core file. So this core file
will start two internal servers,
one those server and one
a normal one.
And there's not so much to it. I
can just according as my score is core
file.
Port numbers are already specified in the core
file, so this should just start.
It does we have the server starting for
the root zone and the those server also
for the root zone on this port.
Skip to this.
So big, like, local host,
any record, who am I?
This will give me a reply.
And you see
where am I replied to me. I got
this data back, which is a bit nonsensical.
It tells who am I, which is my
IP address and port number I was asking
the question on and the protocol.
It's a bit silly, but it's a nice
tool for debug things and demos like this.
Nice. You also see it it's locked,
which is what the lock plug in do
does.
So
I prepared
little shell script.
This goes to the other port fourteen forty
three,
and it asks the same question over
HPS.
It's a bit silly.
The
actual ID is always zero, which is
not how it should be. The buffer size,
because we are asking of TCP
defaults to this value, that's all
details.
But you see here that we actually query
CoreDNS
on this URL because it's it's PS,
and we got a similar answer.
You see here,
it's TCP because of HTTPS.
Different ports, but we're still coming from local
host. So this works. You can just use
CoreDNS
as a server that does go.
A quick will be added once that's fully
specified.
One thing we're not doing yet is we
can't forward queries to
DNS over HTTP server.
We are missing a plug in that does
that.
Cool.
Do
you see
DNS over HTTPS?
Just is that the new standard now? Would
you say always default to that if possible?
I mean, are there any considerations that people
should be making with, like you know, start
with the UDP approach and then bring it
and phase it in? Like, what what's your
thoughts on that?
So
with dough,
browser's good is now native.
Meaning the whole DNS ecosystem was always you
need to upgrade every box on Earth to
actually have your code being deployed
in the resolve of all the machines.
And now Google just pushes out a new
version of Chrome, and everybody is using an
upgraded version of of DNS or HPS.
And there's this whole thing, what I said,
like,
DNS was plain text.
DNSSEC didn't change that. It just added signatures.
So with DOE, for the first time, you
actually can't inspect DNS traffic,
which is
interesting
in certain parts of the world or maybe
all of them, but that's a whole whole
different discussion.
So that's that's one of the main drivers
for for DNS of HTTPS.
I I I don't wanna divert too much,
but I'll ask one more question. Does the
metrics, the CoreDNS exposed, does that give me
a breakdown over the quest the protocol that
was handled? Will it tell me if it
was DNS or HTTPS or whether it was
plain DNS?
No. I think we only do UDP TCP,
which which might be an interesting thing to
to add.
Okay. Cool. I'll play around with that.
Yeah.
We see? Yeah. We can definitely see how
it comes in. So it might actually be
a nice thing to
to have. Running both UDP service and HPS
service is kind of strange because then you
don't have nobody can see my queries because
you're still doing the the plain old QDP.
But a fair point.
Oh,
scrolling the wrong wrong window.
On those multiple servers
so this is a a core file
that defines
two servers, basically, two internal coordinate servers.
One serves the example of our domain on
port 53,
and the other one serves the example.net
domain on 53.
So these are
the same listener, but internally, this means there
are two servers in CoreDNS
responding to queries for these two
domains.
And you can see the difference, which I
will show.
One of the servers will lock because it
has the lock
plug in, and the other one will stay
silent and won't do anything.
Now that if you enable
the log plug in,
if you have a busy server and you
are logging a lot, that will
take away some performance.
I'm not going back to my terminal.
I'll stop this.
So this is the core file
from the slides.
Same here. I populated all these directories with
the CoreDNS part of me, so to make
it nice and easy.
We started, it prints out, all this the
mini servers that's running. So those are those
those two.
We can do the same thing as as
just now.
I have a deck,
for example, .net. So this shouldn't show anything
on the CoreDNS site, which it didn't because
it didn't have the log, plugin.
But if I'll ask one for org,
it does give a logline because it has
a login
that says it does must do so.
All all what you see here is it's
pretty basic.
This is the
remote address, so the reason for asking.
I can't actually remember what this was, but
this is what the
question was.
Protocol
size of the incoming request.
Do I want DNSSEC
or not?
And what my UDP buffer is?
And then this stuff is the actual answer.
So we didn't see an error.
The answer was a 12 bytes, and it
took this amount of time to actually generate
it.
And some of this stuff is also in
the in the metrics if you have metrics
enabled.
K.
So is it a standard practice for like
looking at that conflict, I mean, and now
knowing that it came from the caddy
kind of background. So those are essentially like
virtual hosts and then you're just gonna using
that some Yep. For that the Genesys response.
Would you run them on different ports, or
would that just always be the same port?
No. You can also run them on different
port. Then you actually get multiple listeners in
the CoreDNS process to pick those up. But
yes.
Okay. Cool. Yeah. I can change the port,
and then I need to change the ports
and then they come on as well. There's
no difference.
Alright. Just curious.
So one of the big things in in
DNS is that it's super hard to debug,
and I will not claim that these following
slides will make you a debug expert because
it's still hard.
Couple of reasons why this is hard, mostly
because the volume of DNS queries are probably
large.
So if one or in a thousand queries
fails, how do you see this one query
failing
even though somebody actually had a problem with
the application because that one query timed out
or whatever?
So that's that's
a thing. And,
but I said logging
on on scale is hard to do. So
it's it's really hard to just find, like,
one in a million queries that timed out
for some reason,
which is why and because CoreDNS is lower
in the stack, anything that that fails to,
properly work here has repercussions,
higher up, which means things
don't work or have a humongous amount of
latency.
So couple of plug ins. We have the
debug plug in.
That's a fairly new thing.
You can lock debug from within a plug
in.
And if you enable the debug plugin, that
actually shows up in your outputs
in standard output.
It also stops CoreDNS recovering from panics.
Panics are both thing. If CoreDNS has out
of bounds read, it will crash.
By default, it will then just restart.
I will not actually crash. It will intercept
the panic and will just continue running.
Furthermore, there's pprof. So there is for go
pprofing.
You could just enable a plug in, connect
to the remote port,
and get a pprof of the binary.
Prometheus already talked about adding metrics,
which you always should,
and trace
those actual open tracing of a request within
CoreDNS.
Those are all useful things to to have,
especially tracing can be can be handy
to just see what's happening. Although it's not
too interesting because usually according as future query
forwards, it's too extreme and then gives back
an answer, which it may or may not
get.
Another thing that we have is DNS step,
which is a gRPC protocol
which forwards all generated queries to a DNS
step endpoint
and will allow you to see
what queries are received by CoreDNS and what
queries CoreDNS itself also does.
And
as with always, it's just enabling a a
plugin. So this stands out of a core
file. We run a server for the root
domain, so we capture all incoming queries.
We will forward them to Google.
We will lock the queries, but we'll also
DNS step the queries to, the socket.
And on the other side, that socket needs
to be running, DNS step binary, which will
show you the queries, being received and the
queries being forward to to Google.
So this can be really, really powerful
in actually seeing and and capturing what is
happening with with this process.
Note that a lot of stuff, especially in
Kubernetes,
we've seen issues where
IP tables are filling up.
So if the query doesn't reach CoreDNS,
this will be useless.
Then you will need to do a step
on your note to actually see where
is the traffic going. And, usually, it's it's
dropped. We've seen it quite a lot of
times in
Kubernetes,
for instance.
Okay. I prepared a demo for this as
well, so I will switch to
my terminal.
Quit.
The core file oh, I've had a debug
for good measure here, which is which is
fine.
So this is the same core file I've
just shown.
Let me start my
DNS test binary.
So this open the sockets unit sockets on
temp unit tap dot sock.
It
will, I think, barf out YAML.
So we should see some YAML if I
start CoreDNS.
We all love YAML.
Yeah.
Yeah. It's also JSON, so maybe I should
have done it.
Let's query this
and allow us for the MX records of
example.
Oh,
dot net.
I'm seeing a bunch of things.
Of course, this is the answer that I
got from CoreDNS.
Don't look at how this looks, but this
is
a valid answer that basically says we don't
have any MXs.
We have a logline because we enable that
as well,
and we all have our DNS step data.
And this is interesting
because,
what you didn't see in the logline is
that we are also
forwarding this to
the server,
and we are asking the same questions, so
that's good. The MX records for example .net.
And then responded.
So we got a forward response,
and you see it here,
which is right now, we see the original
query coming in, so it's a bit of
ordering. It it makes sense if you know
what's happened, but this is the query going
into CoreDNS,
which is indeed
asking for this.
And this is the actual response that we
sent back, which is the forward message we
received.
So these are four data points, two queries
sent and two queries received, which you don't
get from the logs and you also don't
see from the date, obviously, because that's just
the the client.
K. And note that the protocol itself is
not UDP based. It's gRPC based.
So it it
it's not as as efficient.
So it might block
or it might build up if you have
a large number of queries getting coordinates. Although,
I don't know what the specific number would
be,
but it's
especially, you can also do DNS step over
TSP.
So there might be
some slowness there. By default, if you can't
DNS step
a message, we will drop it because we
can't wait for DNISTEP to
be ready for us.
But this is a very useful debugging tool
that I don't think a lot of people
know about.
Yeah. I mean, there's this obviously, there's this
meme. Right? Every time something goes wrong, it's
always DNS. And I think the visibility here
that I can see DNS tap given people
would probably help them debug those things
so much quicker
than the long drawn out way that I
I can say from experience I've spent looking
at DNS problems. So I wish I had
known this existed a long time ago.
Yeah. But you have to have the bandwidth
to actually get all this data. You have
to store it maybe for a couple of
days.
In this format, it's it's pretty voluminous, so
it's it's it might be a lot of
data that you need to catch. But, yes,
it totally doable with with But it has
that output format. Right? You chose YAML, but
I could have chose JSON. So I'm assuming
I could, you know, hook in a little
bit of tooling to pull out the fields
I need and store them in, you know,
a TSDB or some other DB and then
Yep. Yep. You know, delete them after seventy
two hours. That's not there when I have
a problem and I wanna fix it. So
I Yep. Yeah. Exactly. And you can actually
look back time stamps for there. So it's
a it's
yep. We can't do this
in our logging for instance because that just
wouldn't scale. So this is a good good
in between.
Oh, yeah. Definitely.
See the the forwarding? So right now,
this
CoreDNS is saying, have I
so I'm a is that say forward the
dot means anything and then if we can't
answer it, to a to a. If I
have another domain in there, like,
can you help me understand how that works?
So let me phrase that question in a
way that makes sense to you.
If I add another
domain, like example.net
to this core file and it doesn't have
a forward, that dot is a wild card.
Is that is my understanding? Oh, yeah. So
basically, what you can do,
let's say you have this,
and you can say
so now you are authoritative,
for example, .org,
but anything on the org, wanna forward. The
rest you wanna handle locally in this
CoreDNS query.
Okay.
And maybe that's just something that you're gonna
cover later, and I'm just jumping the gun
a little bit.
About
can I also have any number of
entries for the
if I want each sub domain on my
domain to be its own
resolver, is that possible too just by adding
extra sub domains?
Does that make sense? Yeah. So you want,
like, you
what do you mean? Like, reload
If I wanted david.example.org
to have its own name server, that's just
a case of doing that. Right? Or Yes.
Although doing this locally in the core file
just makes CoreDNS know about it. If you
wanna do the proper delegation, you need somebody
else actually pointing your
well, you need to buy domain and go
through all those things. But, yes,
once you've done that, you can just add
the name here.
Okay. I'm just gonna keep these questions coming
until you tell me to show up now.
But it says the forward use the same
protocol that I query. So if I query
over
DNS over HTTPS, does it forward in the
same protocol, or does it forward over UDP
to my default?
By default, this is UDP.
There are options.
I think force TCP,
which will force a TCP connection to the
upstream.
The one thing that we did implement, because
it was fairly easy, is we leave this
syntax,
which
should actually work nowadays,
means use DNS over
TCP.
I don't know. Use DNS over TLS,
which is a different protocol than DNS over
HTTPS.
Basically,
this is a raw TCP connection and you
do TLS handshake on it.
So this is supported. We have
a gRPC plugin,
which is similar to forward, but uses gRPC
in a protocol we invented
to talk to an upstream.
What we don't have is
an HTTPS
forwarder that actually talks DOE to an upstream
that doesn't exist.
Okay.
So we can do though on the, like,
the the the entrance side into CoreDNS,
but we can't speak it to an upstream
yet.
Okay. Cool.
Okay. Let me switch back now.
Yeah. What I said, If this doesn't give
you the data you want, you definitely need
to teach speed ups. That's also useful for
book reporting on the CoreDNS repo.
If you have a really strange case, I
will probably ask teach speed up or account
debug.
Now a slight detour on from operational to
some go code.
I will show you an actual plugin, which
is
fairly
fairly simple.
As said, we are using the go language.
So a plugin is
a thing that implements the plugin plugin interface,
which means in in our case that you
need to implement the serve DNS,
which is the meat of the plug in
and the name method.
And we have an example plug in, which
is on CoreDNS
slash example repo,
which prints the words example on every query
it sees, so it doesn't do a lot.
But the code is is basically here.
We have our
structure that we defined. Example, in this case,
we have a serve DNS method,
catch a context,
a DNS response writer. If you've ever programmed
with the a net HP package,
this looks simple similar except
it's DNS instead of HP,
and the request
the incoming request.
The thing does something, it returns a status
code and error.
And in this case, we make a new
response rider,
which we will see in the next slide,
and we call into our plug in chain
to further handle
the request.
Or if nothing is to be done, we
are done and we will return on.
So the new response printer thing
that is here,
and, the meat of this
is this bit.
Once we are done, we will call write
message, which will write the message back to
the client asking,
for a response.
We have a response,
which is, either forwarded or whatever. We don't
know at this point. We have just a
response that we need to write back.
So this is
printing out
example,
which is what this plug in does,
and then it just writes
calls the underlying response writer, calls its right
message method,
and they'll write the method.
We will write the response back to the
client.
And these can be wrapped, so this can
be, calling into caching,
which you can call into logging, and it
just unwraps the whole thing until the client
actually sees the bytes, being returned.
And that's it.
And in this case, you don't need to
know anything about DNS. You just write a
couple of lines of go, and you have
a plug in.
It's not always that easy.
That's pretty simple, actually. To be honest, I
was just I figured the plug ins would
have a little bit I guess there's more
to it than that, but the the base
skeleton actually is not that daunting at all.
Yeah. Yeah. And we're trying actively to to
make, like, the core of CoreDNS to do
most of the the DNS stuff. So you
can actually focus on just writing Go code,
and you just hook it in, and it
works.
Sadly, there are many core cases in the
DNS which you need to think about. But,
yeah, in in essence, we wanna make
open up DNS for for people to just
use this. So one of the things we're
seeing is that the crypto people,
there's like
some naming scheme they have on the
in
some bit Bitcoin coin,
and they wrote a plug in in CoreDNS
that works on the on the blockchain and
does some naming.
Yeah. I was going through the plug in
list earlier,
and I noticed the the Ethereum DNS server
plug in, which is kind of sitting there,
and I found that, you know, quite interesting
that quite it's not just the Kubernetes community
and the cloud native community, but, you know,
the brighter technology community is is now coming
to CoreDNS and adding their their own plug
ins to it, I thought was really cool.
Yep. Yep. No. I think so too. I
have no idea what a thing actually does,
but it's just not you know, that pro
prototype and just make the thing
easily work in in CoreDNS.
Much harder than doing it in mind, for
instance, or or MSB. I don't know about
PowerDNS.
So so that's it. So yeah. We, of
course, use CoreDNS ourselves to host
CoreDNS.io,
which is one of the things we wanna
move to another fly, but they don't do
IPv6
and
hosting our own DNS there is is
more interesting. So for now, we just host
this on a
on a Linux machine.
And the core file that we have for
CoreDNS,
the buyer, looks like this.
So we have a snippet as it's called,
because I'm using this to serve more
domains.
So this this defines that we have Prometheus
errors debug
and any.
Any is another small
plugin
that
replies to any queries with the h info.
Any replies can be really, really big, so
they are used for amplification attacks.
With any plugin, you just sidestep the whole
problem.
And then for CoreDNS.io,
it's a domain we serve, so we spell
it out in the core file.
And we have a couple of things here.
We use the sign plug in
to DNSSEC
sign
CoreDNS.io
because
I've done DNSSEC. I thought it should be
signed with
should be using DNSSEC.
We have some keys on system that just
signs this stuff.
Then we use the file plug in
to pick up this sign zone,
which
is created by the sign plug in and
serve the contents.
Then we have the transfer plug in that
tells you if, the zone has changed,
ping those other servers because we need them
to pick up the new contents that we
have.
And then we import base,
which means we also have the plug ins
that we have on the on the left
side here.
These things make
DNS access zones
hassle free. It will just resign
and will do the right thing.
And you can see this from logging.
So the logs from
according the s and o, I grabbed this,
like, yeah, a couple of days ago.
The sign plug in
is telling me that it's just resigned
CoreDNS IO because the signatures are too old,
and they have a lifetime because a bit
deeper what DNSSEC is. But they have a
lifetime, so you have to resign those things
every so often. Otherwise,
your zone will go bad.
So, thankfully, this worked.
It will save some more bits, like when
I'm gonna sign again.
A super small zone, so the signing
took no time at all.
But then you see that the file plugin
sees that the CoreDNS IO zone had been
reassigned or changed in that file, and it
picks up the new file
and serves the new data.
When file that does this, it will then
ping the transfer plugin,
which will send
notifies as they are called to the other
servers like you guys. I have a new
a new zone. You need to pick it
up, and you need to get the new
data from me.
So here you see all the plugins, like,
in the actual plugin chain, just ticking those
boxes one by one and just, have the
whole thing automated
without me doing anything,
which is why I wanted to sign plug
in because before this, had a Chrome job,
which was a bit crummy.
So I'm curious about that
transfer plug in whereas notifying another IP address.
Like, as our is this, like
is CoreDNS horizontally scalable?
Is that my misunderstanding?
This this is a yeah. That's
an old feature of DNS servers.
But, yeah, the the proper term now would
be horizontal to each cable. Yes.
So that is that just two core fails
that are the same being run by the
binary but on different machines? Is that is
that all I do?
Yep. Yep. Well, preferably, you will run that
somebody else runs a different binary in a
different org.
So these are a couple of old friends
of mine who actually run a different DNS
server,
but it it serves the same day.
Okay. Cool.
I'm contemplating making a thing that uses bit
current to do this,
but it turned out to be somewhat complex.
That's all. I mean, as long as we
control both ends, so you're both
ends with the coordinates, we are super free
in what we can do.
But this the notifies and the transfer is
the standard DNS protocol. Alright. Okay. Cool. Which
is a different protocol than normal query and
also protocol.
Cool.
This is my last slide.
So what are we gonna do in in
CoreDNS?
Well,
the usual bug fixing and and keeping up
to date with with Kubernetes,
which is moving fast,
adding dual stack support, which is super nice
and some other API stuff that's that's been
done there.
Furthermore, a couple of couple of new plug
ins that are core to DNS.
There is one to minimize
responses,
which is saves bandwidth and application attacks.
DNS cookies is a thing to actually make
sure you're talking to the right server, which
you might implement as a plug in.
One thing that I've been pushing back is
new storage plug ins
because, a, they are quite complex and they
vendor the entire world. So I think we
we we have a lot of stuff that
we
need to pull down to compile according to
us mostly because of we're using actually
cloud DNS
route 53
Azure,
a whole bunch of these, and all those
plugins look similar.
So we need some kind of generic plugin
where you can hook in all these to
to make that scale again, I think. So
for now, I I I've had enough of
adding identical code to go to a slightly
better one. So I'm putting
my foot down unless there's a good reason
to actually include
something super new and novel.
Okay. So we got it from my side.
Alright. So if anyone watching has any questions,
feel free to drop them in the comment
section now. I have a a few that
I prepared that I'll I'll run over just
now then.
And I think my first question actually very
luckily ended on this a similar note to
what you're talking about there like,
what when I was looking at the website
earlier and I realized there's plugins and external
plugins, it kinda reminded me of a problem
we had on the telegraph project.
The telegraph project is a collection agent for
metrics.
But they started off as a plugin based
thing, but all the plugins were compelled in.
The the telegraph project today has like over
plugins. The project size, the binary is huge,
the vendor, wow, the vendors like
and I think that's a very goal problem.
Right? Like goal problem there's not a good
plugin mechanism
that works with goal.
And I'm curious about external plugins and how
that works in CoreDNS. It's a gRPC, http,
something else. Maybe you could help me understand
that a little bit. So so what is
your exact question? Like, how do you get
them in, or how do we deal with
the like, value move from external to internal?
So as the external plugin is just not
hosted in the CoreDNS repository, but it's still
compiled in, or are you doing some magic
at runtime to pull an external plugins as
No. No. So
if you wanna have an external plugin, you
need to
exchange
plugin dot config to actually add the lines
to point to the external plugin,
then I go generate and then I go
build.
Ah, okay. So that's the understanding problem then
for Go projects is how how do we
have external plug ins that could be dynamically
linked or something like that? Yeah. There's this
plug in interface, but I haven't dealt looked
into that. So if if we're gonna go
that route, that would be a a massive
rewrite, which means we can also look in
in the plugin ordering because we lose the
plugin with config file probably.
But, yeah, I I'm I'm happy enough with
CoreDNS as is that I don't consider this
personally a big big thing that I need
to fix in in CoreDNS.
Okay. Cool.
So I'm curious also about, you know, we
we touched on I kind of misinterpreted the
transfer plug in for something to do with,
you know, scaling a DNS server. But I'm
also curious about the the bad actor side
of that. Like, you know, DNS attacking DNS
servers can be a
popular vector, I guess, for people that want
to bring down
or take over DNS zones and stuff like
that. Does CoreDNS have plugins or anything that
allows me to do to to try and
protect myself?
There is an external plug in called response
rate limiting,
which means that if we see a lot
of
queries from same IP,
we will will do some blocking. That's not
a default plug in.
Usually,
if you there's several ways. Like, if you
wanna
interact with with the registration and the current
stuff,
that's not something CoreDNS itself can help with.
I mean, it just serves whatever is in
the core file. So if if somebody gets
into that trajectory,
then
so be it.
The transfer itself, there is some very limited
things you can do to securities,
which also shows the age of of
DNS protocol.
There's a a symmetric key you can configure,
IP white listing, that kind of stuff, which
is all,
in my book, pretty old school things to
actually make sure you receive the correct data.
The best way to make a DNS server
not responsive is just
DDoSs and then fill the pipe,
and there's not much you can do at
that point.
Okay.
I'm I'm assuming
your
personal domains are all hosted by CoreDNS.
Is is that a correct assumption?
Yeah. Yeah. Yeah. Yeah. Yep. Yeah. The snippet
that I showed you on the recording that
showed, that's why all the domains there as
well.
Of course. Alright. I'll give you two proper
questions though instead of that. So,
you know, obviously,
I think a lot of people are familiar
with CoreDNS because of the adoption of of
Kubernetes and CoreDNS into that project. Like, with
the whole advent of cloud native architectures and
micro services becoming a new norm for teams
and organizations,
does that allow or afford DNS to play
a newer role in those architectures or take
on new responsibilities?
So, yeah, there was a
massive influx of popularity once we got into
the CNCF.
Although, a humongous amount of bugs that we
fixed because people were were not actually using
it.
So one of the things we try to
do with gRPC
is we can probably move away from UDP
if everything is
courting us,
which means we can use new protocols and
can do interesting things. One of the things
we have with gRPC
was that you could watch names to be
changed.
In the DNS right now, you have to
wait until the TTL expires and that kind
of stuff. But the gRPC, we could just
kinda watch back like this name has changed.
You need to update it, which would mean
that the updates
in Kubernetes, for instance, would be instantaneously
instead of just waiting for it to deal
to time out.
So that would be interesting, but then
this all falls flat because you also need
to change the clients to actually use your
new Fangled protocol.
Meaning,
at the time,
local
DNS node node local
what is it?
Node DNS local, whatever the hell they have
right now. Every
node in the DNS in the Kubernetes cluster
runs CoreDNS.
So we can all potentially actually do this.
We could probably switch to gRPC
and have some other protocol than
DNS
doing the naming in those clusters.
Alright. Cool. That actually kinda leads on. We
we had a a viewer question, and the
the question was, are there any best practices
for using DNS in Kubernetes?
And I'd also like to kind of just
throw something else into there like, you mentioned
that you previously worked on SkyDNS,
which I think was the original cube DNS
like Yep. Yep. What
why was that deprecated in favor of CoreDNS?
Like, what were some of the differences changes?
What lessons did we learn from that kind
of older approach?
So to start with that, so SkyDNS was
the SkyDNS binary combined with
DNS mask,
which was another c
DNS
binary.
And there was
at some moment, couple of years back,
where they had
eight
CFEs in DNS mask. So that was a
a thing they needed to upgrade. Also, the
interaction between the two because you have two
boundaries getting more complex. So so CoreDNS
basically unified at all, gave problem metrics, all
that kind of stuff. So it's it's easier
to deploy one CoreDNS
than it is to have SkyDNS and DNS
Mask.
So that was a bit of the impetus
on on why moving to,
CoreDNS.
Doing DNS in Kubernetes clusters is tricky
for a couple of reasons.
There's a thing called the search path
and the kind of options
you can have,
which means
if you have
a domain like ...google.com,
the entire search path will be searched before
it will actually try wwwgoogle.com.
Meaning, every query that is done in the
Kubernetes cluster
leads to a five x amplification of the
number of queries we see in CoreDNS.
So that alone is
horrendous
and should be fixed, although it can't be
fixed anymore. So the number of queries that
we see is is way more than need
to be done, which means you need to
scale CoreDNS
aggressively
or your DNS and and process aggressively to
actually be able to respond to all those
queries.
We have a couple of text that's
sidestep this. There is
auto path, which makes this this it shortcuts
your search path because we know what you're
looking for, so we will tell you what
the actual answer is. But that's quite a
hack.
So if you wanna know if things are
performing well, use metrics.
The health plug in has an internal loop
that tells you how busy the core and
that's binary is. So you can use that
for for latency. If that goes through the
roof, then something is clearly wrong.
Latency on on DNS request is also good
to track. Sysdig had an article yesterday
on exactly that. So you need to be
on top of things to see see what's
happening. And if you look at the metrics,
you see that non existing domains is 9%
of all periods.
Yeah. The many you said that search path
thing, like, got innocent flashbacks. Like,
when Kubes DNS was the default at our
clusters,
we
we pretty much dead denial of service attacker
entire infrastructure
with them and a request that we're going
through. And the the configuration is that's it
was the end of its problem. Right? I
think by default end of its set to
like five or something like that. Yeah. Cousin
five x number of lookups that we actually
want to do. I mean, you have a
high number of lookups,
The whole thing was found out. Yeah. Yeah.
The default on your Linux box is to
for handles to give a sense of how
how far along they they were. Another thing
that's
you should probably do in your Kubernetes cluster
is normally you have two DNS servers that
are useful for clients.
In Kubernetes clusters, there's one service IP and
all clients go to this. So if that's
overloaded,
a client will just need a degree. So
once you have a cascading failure, it's there's
no way we can come out of this.
So what you should have is have two
sets of core DNS
serving two different
service IPs
and then updating all your notes to have
those two IPs in the result of the
comp.
And then at least client can move to
the other one, which is maybe
less loaded than the previous one.
Yeah. That's a great tip, actually. That's nice.
I wish I was involved in these decisions
when they were made in Kubernetes,
but yeah.
There there's tough time. It's not it's you
can, you know, fail the cat. We can
get that changed. We can make it better.
I mean, think it's the
first part that's that will never change.
Alright. I don't think we have any more
questions. So with that, I'll just say, you
know, thank you for
joining me today. That was really insightful and
you know, getting
your experience and your understanding of the project
and the demos and just getting a good
look into how CoreDNS functions and how the
plug ins work like all of that was
great. So thank you for taking the time
to join me today. Cool. Thanks for having
me. Alright. Well, you have a a great
evening. I know it's getting late where you
are, so I won't keep you much longer.
But again, a pleasure and I'll speak to
you soon. Cool. Great. Thanks. Bye bye.